>>> JUST A SHORT TIME AGO THE
FORMER PRESINT OFFERED HIS
ENDORSEMENT  A KEY SENATE RACE
IN MISSOURI.
HE ENDORSED ERIC, LEAVING IT
OPEN FOR VOTERS TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN THE TWO ERICS ACTUALLY
IN THE RACE.
ONE OF WHOM THE FORMER GOVERNOR
RESIGNED FROM OFFICE FOUR YEARS
AGO AFTER A SEX SCANDAL AND IS
NOW FACING ALLEGATIONS OF ABUSE
FROM HIS EX-WIFE, WHICH HE
DENIES.
CNN'S JEFF ZELENY HAS MORE.
>> GUYS, WE ARE ON OUR WAY TO
VICTORY.
>> Reporter: ERIC GROIGTEN
SEEKING A COME BACK IN MISSOURI.
>> THEY RUN A CAMPAIGN BASED ON
FEAR, WE RUN A CAMPAIGN BASED ON
FAITH AND HOPE.
AND THE FACT IS THAT THE COUNTRY
IS IN CRISIS.
>> Reporter: HE'S NOT TALKING
ABOUT RIVAL DEMOCRATS BUT FELLOW
REPUBLICANS, TRYING TO BLOCK HIS
SECOND ACT.
SAYING HE'S UNFIT FOR OFFICE AND
COULD ENDANGER THE GOP'S CHANCES
OF WINNING THE SENATE.
ON THE EVE OF VOTING THE
MISSOURI SENATE PRIMARY FEELS
LIKE A HOT SUMMER MUD FIGHT.
>> SCANDALS, CHILD ABUSE
ALLEGATIONS.
THAT'S NOT CONSERVATIVE, BUT
THAT'S THE REAL ERIC GREITENS.
>> HE'S ABUSED HIS WIFE AND KID
AND HE'S QUIT ON THE PEOPLE OF
THIS STATE.
>> Reporter: HE TOLD US THE
SENATE SEAT IS TOO
TOO MUCH TO RISK.
>> WE CAN'T LOSE MISSOURI.
YOU KNOW, THE FORMER GOVERNOR
SAY QUITTER AND WOULD CERTAINLY
JEOPARDIZE THIS RACE.
>> CONGRESSWOMAN HEIGHT LETTER
SAYS GREITENS HAS BROUGHT SHAME
TO THE STATE.
>> I CAN'T VOTE FOR HIM.
MISSOURI DESERVES BETTER THAN
THAT AND IT CAN DO BETTER.
I HAVE THAT TRACK RECORD OF
CONSERVATIVE, COURAGEOUS
LEADERSHIP THAT IS NEEDED RIGHT
NOW.
>> THE SCANDAL DATES BACK TO
2018 WHEN GREITENS STEPPED DOWN
AS GOVERNOR AFTER ACKNOWLEDGING
AN AFFAIR WITH HIS HAIRDRESSER.
SHE ACCUSED HIM OF TRYING TO
BLACKMAIL HER.
HE AND HIS WIFE ARE EMBROILED IN
A NASTY CUSTODY BATTLE.
THE FORMER NAVY SEAL HAS SOUGHT
TO CHANGE THE SUBJECT BY TAKING
AIM AT THE REPUBLICAN
ESTABLISHMENT.
>> TODAY WE'RE GOING R.H.I.N.O.
HUNTING.
THERE'S NO BAGGING LIMIT, NO
TAGGING LIMIT, AND IT DOESN'T
EXPIRE.
>> Reporter: HE CALLS THEM
R.H.I.N.O.S.
IN ALL 21 GOP CANDIDATES ARE
RUNNING, INCLUDING MARK
McCLOSKEY, WHO SEEKS TO
CAPITALIZE ON THE MOMENT HE AND
HIS WIFE POINTED GUNS AT
PROTESTERS OUTSIDE THEIR HOME
TWO YEARS AGO.
TONIGHT DONALD TRUMP'S DAY-LONG
PROMISE OF AN ENDORSEMENT
BROUGHT LITTLE CLARITY.
HE SAID, I TRUST THE GREAT
PEOPLE OF MISSOURI ON THIS ONE
TO MAKE UP THEIR OWN MINDS.
IF GREITENS WINS, DEMOCRATS
BELIEVE THEY HAVE A SHOT AT
PICKING UP THE SEAT, DESPITE NOT
WINNING THE SENATE SEAT HERE IN
NEARLY A DECADE.
>> WE'VE GOT TO RUN DIFFERENT.
WE'VE GOT TO RUN AGAINST THE
SYSTEM THAT'S NOT WORKING FOR
EVERYBODY.
AND YOU'VE GOT TO BE A WARRIOR
FOR PEOPLE.
>> I WANT TO BRING IN DAVID
CHALIAN TO THE CONVERSATION.
DAVID, WHAT ARE YOU LEARNING
ABOUT THIS MOVE?
HOW ARE MISSOURI VOTERS EXPECTED
TO REACT TO THIS?
>> ANDERSON, I THINK THEY ARE
LIKELY TO BE LEFT TO THEIR OWN
DEVICES, WHICH IS WHAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT SAID.
HE SAID THE GOOD PEOPLE OF
MISSOURI SHOULD MAKE UP THEIR
MINDS.
HE'S CLEARLY TRYING TO SAVE FACE
HERE.
HE CLEARLY IS MINDFUL OF HIS OWN
SCORECARD, AS HE HAS BEEN
THROUGHOUT THIS PRIMARY SEASON.
HE WANTS TO PICK WINNERS.
QUITE SIMPLY, HE DOESN'T KNOW
WHO IS GOING TO WIN IN THIS
CONTEST.
HIS FAMILY MEMBERS ARE
SUPPORTING THE FORMER GOVERNOR,
ERIC GREITENS.
A LOT OF OTHER REPUBLICANS ARE
SUPPORTING THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
ERIC SCHMID.
SO, HE CAME DOWN TO SAY HE IS
ENDORSING THE ERICS, BUT
BASICALLY LEAVING IT TO VOTERS.
AND AT SUCH THE 11th HOUR, IT IS
TOO LATE REALLY TO GET A NEW TV
AD UP.
BOTH ERICS WERE CLAIMING VICTORY
TONIGHT ON THE ENDORSEMENT.
BUT THE VOTERS ARE ALREADY GOING
TO MAKE UP THIERN MINDS.
THEY KNOW THESE CANDIDATES ALL
TOO WELL.
>> DAVID, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THIS 11th HOUR MOVE BY THE
FORMER PRESIDENT?
>> I THINK BECAUSE HE WAITED SO
LONG, IT'S A DIMINISHING EFFECT
OF WHAT HIS ENDORSEMENT COULD
ACCOMPLISH.
AND ALTHOUGH HE WAS CLEARLY
BEING LOBBIED AND SWAYED FROM
BOTH SIDES HERE, I THINK HE
REALIZED THAT HE MAY NOT BE THE
DIFFERENCE MAKER IN THIS ONE,
ANDERSON.
SO, WHY TAKE ON THE POTENTIAL
BAGGAGE BACKING THE WRONG GUY AT
THE END OF THE DAY.
>> JEFF, LOOKING TO THE ARIZONA
PRIMARY TOMORROW, THERE'S THIS
PROXY BATTLE BETWEEN FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE.
BOTH HAVE BEEN ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL FOR DIFFERENT CANDIDATES.
HOW MUCH IS AT STAKE FOR BOTH?
>> LOOK, I THINK A LOT IS AT
STAKE FOR THE FORMER PRESIDENT,
OF COURSE.
THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT IS
CLEARLY NOT AS POPULAR AMONG THE
BASE.
BUT I THINK THE BIGGEST THING AT
STAKE IS THE DIRECTION OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IN ARIZONA.
ONE OF THE TOP BIG BATTLEGROUNDS
IN THIS CYCLE.
AND THE FORMER PRESIDENT WAS OUT
THERE JUST A WEEK OR SO AGO.
HE IS ENDORSING KARI LAKE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S RACE.
AND THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
HAS ENDORSED ANOTHER CANDIDATE.
THE CURRENT GOVERNOR IS ALSO
BACKING HER, KARRIN TAYLOR R
ROBSON.
WHICH DIRECTION IS THE PARTY
GOING TO GO?
IT IS STILL TRUMP POLICY, BUT IT
IS A DIFFERENT TYPE OF A
RHETORIC, IF YOU WILL.
AND KARI LAKE IS AS BIG OF AN
ELECTION DENIER AS IT COMES.
IF SHE WINS TOMORROW IN ARIZONA
AND SOME OTHER CANDIDATES AS
WELL, THEY WILL CERTAINLY
FORESHADOW A ROUGH RACE, AN
INTERESTING RACE, COME NOVEMBER.
>> DAVID, THERE'S ANOTHER KEY
PRIMARY CHASE AFTER THE CAPITOL
ATTACK.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO WATCH FOR
IN THAT RACE?
>> CONGRESSMAN MEYER IS ONE OF
TEN REPUBLICANS WHO VOTED TO
IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT.
HE'S ONE OF THREE ON THE BALLOT
TOMORROW IN PRIMARIES, ANDERSON
TWO, IN WASHINGTON STATE AND
MEYER IN MICHIGAN.
HIS TRUMP-BACKED CHALLENGER,
JOHN GIBBS, IS A TOTAL ELECTION
DENIER AS WELL, HAS PROMOTED
DONALD TRUMP'S LIES ABOUT THE
RESULT OF THE 2020 ELECTION,
SERVED IN THE HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT CABINET AGENCY IN
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
AND HE IS THE CONSERVATIVE
CHOICE HERE, MEYERS IN THE FIGHT
OF HIS LIFE.
AND DEMOCRATS, ANDERSON, ARE
ACTUALLY MEDDLING IN THIS
REPUBLICAN PRIMARY.
THEY'RE SPENDING MONEY TRYING TO
PUMP UP GIBBS BECAUSE THEY THINK
HE'LL BE EASIER TO DEFEAT IN
NOVEMBER.
THAT'S PLAYING WITH FIRE, OF
COURSE, BECAUSE THEY'RE
PROMOTING A KNOWN ELECTION
DENIER, WHO COULD POTENTIALLY WIN THE SEAT IN NOVEMBER
LET'S BRING IN CNN POLITICAL
COMMENTATORS, S.E. CUPP AND
JONAH GOLDBERG, FOUNDER AND
EDITOR-IN-CHIEF OF THE DISPATCH.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE BOTH EVER YOU
HERE.
LET'S START WITH THE EPIC TROLL
KNOWN AS THE ENDORSEMENT OF THE
ERICS.
THIS IS THE WEIRDEST THINGS.
TRUMP SAYS HIGH TAKES
ENDORSEMENT, EVE OF THE PRIMARY
AND COMES OUT WITH AN
ENDORSEMENT THAT SAYS,
THEREFORE, THAT'S WHY I'M PROUD
TO ANNOUNCE THAT ERIC HAS MY
COMPLETE AND TOTALLY
ENDORSEMENT.
THE TWO CANDIDATES ARE OF COURSE
NAMED ERIC.
WHAT IS GOING ON, S.E.?
>> I CALL THIS THE HEY YOU
ENDORSEMENT.
WHEN YOU DON'T REMEMBER WHO IS
GOING IN, YOU SAY, HEY, YOU.
TOTALLY NONCOMMITTAL.
THERE WAS A POINT TO THIS,
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T WANT TO
CHOOSE.
ON A SERIOUS NOTE, THIS IS FAIR,
BUT AGAIN, HOW UNMOTIVATED TRUMP
IS BY IDEAS AND PRINCIPLES AND
POLICIES.
REALLY, HE JUST WANTS THE
ALLEGIANCE.
WHICHEVER GUY IS GOING TO FIGHT
OVER ME THE MOST IS FINE WITH
ME.
HE DOESN'T CARE WHAT IDEAS WIN.
HE ACCOMPLISHES THAT WITH THE
HEY YOU ENDORSEMENT.
>> YEAH, I THINK S.E.'S PRETTY
MUCH NAILED IT, BUT IF IT
REMAINS A JOKE THAT COULD BE
G
FUNNY.
IF IT WAS SURELY LIKE A TROLL,
YOU KNOW, HIM BASICALLY WINKING
AT PEOPLE SAYING I DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO HERE, IT WOULD BE ONE
THING.
BUT HE'S GOING TO, LIKE, PLAY IT
SERIOUSLY AFTERWARDS OR PROBABLY
WILL.
>> MY FAVORITE PART, THOUGH, THE
TRUMP TEAM SAID IN A STATEMENT,
THE ENDORSEMENT SPEAKS FOR
ITSELF.